[Music]
2020 the year kovit 19 caused a global
shutdown but has the virus
changed the british way of life for good
i must give the british people a very
simple
instruction you must stay at home
stay at home protect our nhs and save
lives
well uh on this special daily podcast
i'm joined by some of our specialist
correspondents
to examine the uk journey so far let me
introduce them you know them all in the
studio with me we have our economics
editor ed
conway science correspondent thomas more
in the screen
skies political editor beth rigby she is
of course in westminster joining them
technology correspondent roland
mannthorp
in his car somewhere who knows on the
road and uh completing our panel sky's
climate change correspondent lisa
holland who's covered the crisis in
gowns
during the course of this pandemic what
a range of
expertise we've got here and let's start
beth with you
and me in actual fact and that moment as
you and i
stood outside we were summoned to
downing street monday march the 23rd
this year and we had boris johnson doing
something
unprecedented outside wartime locking
down the nation
you must stay home and i remember that
sense of kind of
electricity going up the hairs on the
back of your neck standing on end
just your thoughts well done it was
an extraordinary moment wasn't it and 27
million people
tuned in to that address by the prime
minister you remember he spoke
uh in that message officially locking
down the country
and i was thinking about it the other
day because i went back
to what the government said on march the
second
when they put out their covid plan and
at the time they said one in five of us
might have to
work from home that the police might
have to patrol
the streets and it all seemed quite
frightening and then with breakneck
speed uh 20 days or so later the
government had locked
the country down taking decisions
momentous decisions
on a daily basis that would affect our
lives our society and of course them
propping up
the economy basically underwriting the
wages of 9.4
million workers so the government in
such a short space of time
kind of moving in ways that we couldn't
imagine and it was just
unbelievable actually to be experiencing
it and to be reporting on it and you as
you said you kind of look back
on what's happened and i still have to
pinch myself uh to believe that it
really happened because it just seems
so extraordinary at the time and looking
back on it it just seems
so extraordinary now and that's the
thing isn't it about
when it happened though roland um come
in on this in the the timing we say
march the 23rd and the and talk about
electricity
coursing through the veins or the spine
or whatever it was that report
from imperial college that had come out
what a week before was it
that led to the lockdown before that
point
we got the sense from the government
that they were going for a so-called
herd immunity
you know for me looking at this pandemic
it's it's been
it's really strange to report in it
there have been times
when i've i've been on air and i've
heard the words coming out of my mouth
and while i've heard them i felt shocked
i felt a little stunned
and one of those moments was immediately
after
neil ferguson one of the key scientists
advising the government
said at a select committee that if we
had locked out a week earlier just
seven days earlier than half the lives
that have lost could have been saved
thinking of the spread that period that
the spread of lockdowns obviously
started
in china and i suppose the rest of the
world went well
it's china that's where it started and
the chinese are able to do that
then i suppose from the european point
of view it was
italy in the north of italy originally
but it still then came as a
huge shock that the united kingdom then
did it but
did it it appears late i think certainly
in the uk and probably europe
as a whole there was a belief that this
was something that wouldn't spread
to to europe that this was an asian
issue it was a coronavirus it wasn't flu
everything had been set up all the
pandemic preparedness was for
uh forced for a flu strain emerging from
that region and then spreading extremely
rapidly and i think that paralyzed
everything that followed
everything was set up for a flu pandemic
not coronavirus you
treat those very differently you don't
need to test and trace for flu
you don't need the the large numbers of
of hospital beds because people
generally don't need that kind of care
certainly not ventilators and i think
that is where we went badly wrong in
those early days that we didn't accept
that there could be a virus out there
with a mortality rate
ten times higher uh that was going to
affect europe
lisa just come in on this and i do
apologize i
i cannot remember where you were
um in late february early march where
you were reporting from
so in mid-march i had access to a care
home
um in london and for me honestly i just
think you could
absolutely see the writing on the wall
that
everything was going down in care homes
at that stage
there was so much fear for a start
amongst
agency workers and remember that a lot
of care homes do have very regular staff
but a lot of other care homes don't have
regular stuff and so they rely on agency
people so it's people who are
not regular faces people who are coming
and going so there was a lot of fear
fear swept through a lot of care homes
like wildfire
people were not showing up for work they
were understaffed they were under
pressure
and then as of course we subsequently
learned they were overwhelmed by the
fact that
it was there was a dawning realization
that they were lower down in the food
chain
i think it's really sad actually as a
sort of thought
looking back at it now that they thought
they were going to be under this big
umbrella that they would be getting the
ppe
and ed i just want to talk to you about
the economic calculations that were made
in terms of the timing of going into
lockdown
the government were well aware at that
point of the economic cost
looking back at it now there is a sense
in there that they were reluctant to do
it because
of the potential hit i think they were
they were to some extent aware of the
cost but you know you've got to remember
that nothing
like this has ever been tried before you
know to lock down an economy it just
hadn't been done and so
you know lots of people were kind of
scrambling around for some sort of
indication of how much
this would impact gdp or employment and
all those things and frankly
a lot of it was kind of stabs in the
dark you know and that even goes for
the bank of england the office of budget
responsibility all these people you know
who produce
the big numbers and you'll remember you
know at the time we were talking about
the biggest hit
gdp gross domestic product since the
17th
18th century you know to 1706 so it's
one of the the years that people talk
about
now this these are kind of you know
almost imponderable
kind of statistics and scenarios all
they knew i think you know within
whitehall was that
to try to take the you know this massive
chunk of the workforce out
would just cause the system to
potentially to not work
and and and the the extent of how can
close that came to genuine catastrophe i
think
it's something we're still kind of
getting our heads around you know we all
or many of us lived through the
financial crisis and we thought that was
going to be
the one moment of economic catastrophe
where the cash machines would stop
working and where the system would seize
up
you know we came very close to that this
time around as well
and that's on top of the obvious
enormous public health
issues we're talking about beth just
before we
leave this opening subject this opening
category
i mean we can't leave it without
mentioning the prime minister himself
ending up in intensive care as he then
subsequently told us
50 50 at death's door yes on march
the 27th it was announced that he had
contracted
the virus and he basically was holed up
uh on his own uh in his flat in downing
street he put a couple of videos out and
you could see
kind of days in there's a sort of point
where do you recover
or do does your condition worsen and i
will never
forget being at downing street on the
night of april the 5th and it was the
queen's
address to the nation and we were all
there
to talk about the queen's address and i
remember coming back to the office
and about quarter past nine this message
landed in my inbox saying the prime
minister had gone into hospital
uh downing street were kind of down
playing it saying he was going
in for tests but i knew it was really
serious because there was no way that
the prime minister
would have wanted to overshadow this
queen
the queen's address while she was
rallying the nation
24 hours later i was in st james's park
actually going for a little walk between
uh the seven o'clock news and waiting to
do the 10 o'clock news
and again i got the message that he'd
gone into intensive care and i remember
running back to college green to go live
and talk about it and my heart really
was in my mouth at that point because
uh that was really frightening we've got
a lot to discuss so we're going to move
on now to
our next section which is care in
crisis the 21st century global pandemic
requires an
unprecedented response and the nhs 19
gale
is just that nhs staff are risking their
own
safety i understand people's anxieties
on the front line
i am now setting the goal of 100
000 tests per day testing is so
important for getting britain back on
our feet what i say to the government is
open the books we know there's been
double counting
we know that some of the tests have been
sent out never made it back
up and down the country relatives and
care home workers are painting a picture
of a sector which is in places close to
collapse
we want to discharge people but they
don't want to test
right from the start we've tried to
throw a protective
ring around our care homes let's examine
that
protective ring claim about all of care
and thomas morlisse has been talking
about it already uh
again a a whole inquiry could be held in
turn will be held into
what went on in care homes but but the
clue wasn't it was
was in the was in the slogans that they
put together their stay home
protect the nhs save lives now of course
care homes
aren't part of the nhs they
presumably did have succeeded in
protecting the nhs but at what cost
the warning signs were there in the data
coming out of china we knew then that
this was a disease that had a mortality
rate of of at least one percent we knew
that it affected the elderly why we
didn't take an early step to protect
care homes is just one of the greatest
scandals of this epidemic here in the uk
we we missed it completely and we should
have taken action
much sooner we didn't give that the
staff the ppe they needed to protect
themselves and the people they were
caring for we discharged people from
hospital
when they needed to clear wards without
testing and there's almost
certainly going to be a large number of
people who went into vulnerable care
homes
with the infection and it then spread
very rapidly
and that has been something that we've
been living with ever since it is
probably why
we continue to have this long lag this
long tail
to this epidemic where other countries
have got back to
reopening their economies much sooner
lisa i mean
you you know this inside out you've been
reporting on this now throughout
the crisis um and i just want to throw
in as you you know you tell us
what has been going on in the games just
take this on board as well
the fact that the prime minister said
well
some of the care homes weren't correctly
following
the procedures were there were they
actually given any real and proper
guidance
on that day when boris johnson went
in he was in a hospital and he went into
intensive care
on that day i broke the story about the
concerns
amongst care homes that they were being
asked to take in
people who were untested so coronavirus
patients who hadn't been given the all
clear
and they were deeply deeply alarmed
about that
and in fact beth and i had discussed on
that day that potentially she was going
to raise that question
uh at the daily briefing to ask the
government about its guidelines which
care homes were saying
added up to a suicide note and
of course then within a few hours boris
johnson went uh into intensive care
and the entire focus was on boris
johnson's health
how do ventilators work there was this
national obsession
with that's where the story was and in
fact
at that time there were already massive
alarm bells raised by care homes and in
particular about this policy
which i reported on on that day
articulated by
i think we're going to hear a clip now
from a man who i interviewed who ran
a care home in torquay graham greenway
and this is what he said
about those guidelines uh that would be
tantamount to importing death into care
homes
the care homes have done all the right
things
against all the odds to add insult to
injury by asking us
to take coded 19 positive patients
is asking us to basically make out
the suicide note for people in
care we surveyed them and said do you
think covered patients being discharged
your care home
caused the virus to spread in your
nursing home and nearly 40 percent
said yes and we also did stories about
care homes who were told that if you
don't take covered patients that haven't
been given the all clear so therefore
could still be
um bringing the virus with them then
they wouldn't get these so-called uplift
payments to help them
pay for the cost of dealing with
coronavirus so to pay for extra costs
like ppe and the like so they felt that
they were really caught between
a rock and a hard place yeah next step
was we reflect on the year so far we're
looking
at scientists and the data
there's a very high likelihood
that come winter we will see an increase
in cases
there's always a question of timing and
there's always a question of what do you
do now
even in the middle of something and be
very clear
we are not at the end of this epidemic
not by a long shot
we're in the middle of it had we
introduced
uh lockdown measures a week earlier we
would have reduced the
final death toll by at least a heart
well that's thomas
following the science that's been one of
the mantras but as we've discovered as
you
well knew before it all happened was
there's no such thing as
the science there is scientific opinion
and
much of that conflicting and it's up to
the politicians then to decide on the
policy
yeah and i think there's been a big
question here whether the the science
has been
diverse enough whether the sage
committee the key advisory committee
that channels all scientific opinions
through to
the ministers to make decisions whether
that has had enough experts
from outside this this core perhaps they
were
guilty of group think and that's why
they got stuck uh on on some issues they
thought it was
uh much like flu they didn't bring in
testing they ignored ppe
they ignored the the care home issue and
just focused on
what they were the the the key issues
listen to scientists outside that group
and the alarm bells were ringing for
them uh
and yet the the sage committee didn't
seem to channel the right advice through
to ministers
and i think there are big questions over
whether ministers
acted fast enough on some of that
scientific advice
and beth in terms of that relationship
between the politicians
and the scientists the wheels came off
the bus so to speak didn't they with
the dominic cummings incident his
decision to travel all that way to
durham
with his family and then controversially
visit barnard castle he said he was
testing his eyesight clearly jonathan
van tan
wasn't very uh happy with that and he
made that statement at that press
conference and he didn't appear
at one of those press conferences again
but i think
actually for me uh the most interesting
moment
um between the prime minister and his
advisers
uh have was actually last friday when
the prime minister
announced a significant easing of
restrictions and then talked about how
come november we might be even able to
stop social
distancing by christmas uh we might be
living in a new normal where where we're
almost back to normal life
and that clearly is in contradiction to
what
both uh sir patrick and chris whitty
professor whitty
have said on the record in recent days
about what they
think and boris johnson i asked him
about that he's very clear
he said at the beginning of march he
followed the science
he then moved to being guided by the
science
and then last week he said we take or
listen to assigned to
scientific advice but as ministers we
make
the decisions now let's move on to our
next
subject as well as the health
implications the country has also taken
a
a massive economic hit of course due to
governor 19 so the fourth area we're
discussing is
rishi to the rescue for the first time
in our history the government is going
to step in
and help to pay people's wages it's
pretty extraordinary
to be honest with you they're talking
about the economy contracting
uh by 35 that's
not uh misspeaking that's not a typos
35 it's unique in modern times um we've
never seen anything like this the uk
is facing a significant recession
well i had to saw you there i mean have
you run out of
historical comparisons i mean i'm quite
serious the great depression
1700 and what the ice age who knows what
the
age of the dinosaurs i mean it's just
unprecedented and when we look back at
this
this period you know i'm i'm kind of
into charts a little bit um
when we look at those you know those
charts you won't be able to look at
any chart of pretty much any economic
measure
for you know without seeing this
enormous
cratering fall in the case of what most
of them
you know enormous rise in the case of
unemployment
one fears in the coming um in the coming
months
this this this has been a period you
know the likes of which we
have never seen in economic terms what's
striking though and you know we saw that
rishi soon at the the chancellor there
is that whereas it's very easy to make
criticisms about
what many other parts of government were
doing you know in
the kind of face of this pandemic the
one bit which
people most most people think has done a
pretty good job is the treasury
stepping into you know with the fellow
scheme nine and a bit million people
on that doing it very quickly breaking
all the rules and let's not forget you
know this is a conservative
government introducing a policy whereby
the state will pay the wages
these these are things which the
treasury never imagined it would have
had to have done
but it actually did them very quickly um
and you know when that inquiry comes
um the assumption is the treasury will
come out of it relatively well but how
much longer can it go on for
a lot of those jobs are now zombie jobs
we're seeing it particularly in the
hospitality
industry those bits that have reopened
well part empty
and that's even with not very many of
them open and make no mistake that you
know the treasury and the chancellor are
well aware that that was the easy stuff
when the furlough scheme is eased off as
it's starting to happen and you know in
the coming months
people will lose their jobs and
companies unfortunately will go to the
wall because as you say some sectors
won't necessarily be able to function in
this new existence some companies will
have struggled already well you've
teed it up nicely for our next sections
ed thank you very much
indeed the race to develop a kovit 19
vaccine took a significant leap forward
on monday scientists in oxford said
their first phase of human trials
showed that doses were safe and induced
an immune response
to the infection so what next for
covid19
the uk is not just developing
world-leading vaccines we're also
putting more money into the global work
for a vaccine
than any other country i think that the
world
health organization should be ashamed of
themselves
because they're like the public
relations agency for china
we're absolutely confident that the
russian intelligence agencies
were engaged in a cyber attack on
research and development
efforts and organizations in this
country and internationally
well next for kovit 19 thomas moore will
there be an effective
vaccine yes i think that is everything
is pointing towards a vaccine
uh that will happen at some stage i
don't think there will be a what they
call a sterilizing vaccine that's one
that
gives 100 protection straight away but
everything
points to a vaccine that can take the
edge off symptoms
with something following behind that
does some kind of long-term protection
and i think that
scientists are increasingly optimistic
okay i liked your direct answer to will
we have one what about
when will we have one that's a much more
difficult question to answer if you
speak to oxford
the team there sarah gilbert is
extremely bullish about being able to
produce a vaccine
perhaps at the end of this year and
we're talking about the first doses
there derma we're not talking about
everybody being protected
if you speak to others robin shattuck at
imperial
he's much more cautious he he doesn't
think that we'll have one until
at least well into next year and i think
that is
a key difference because it's an econo
economic cost the longer we're living in
some kind of restriction
uh the the greater the cost to the
economy uh and indeed
health in general thank you all very
much indeed beth rigby roland mantha
lisa holland thomas more
ed conway thank you all very much indeed